and now I'd like to introduce today's
speaker professor Sam Savage dr. Sam
Savage is an executive director of
probability management org a 501 C 3
non-profit devoted to the communication
and calculation of the uncertainty the
organization has received funding from
Chevron Lockheed Martin PG&E and others
and he's joined on the board by Harry
Markowitz Nobel laureate and economics
dr. Savage is the author of the flow of
averages why we underestimate risk in
the face of uncertainty as an adjunct
professor in civil environmental
engineering at Stanford University he's
the inventor of the stochastic
information packet also known as si P an
auditable data array from conveying
uncertainty dr. Savage received his PhD
in computational complexity from Yale
University my name is pinky Medina and
I'm the program manager that academic
programs team at the Stanford center for
professional development and I will be
moderating today's webinar and the Q&A
session now I'd like to turn the floor
over to Sam thanks Nicky so here's
here's my first question for the
audience have you had at least one
statistics course in your career yes or
no typically if you have it doesn't take
more than 45 minutes to repair the
damage okay we have a lot of people who
have taken statistics let's go on to the
next question if you have one was it's a
high point of your week you still suffer
from PTSD or other
other okay well I don't know what other
means but I'll proceed is if you you
know have not necessarily gotten
anything out of your statistics course
and we're sort of start from scratch so
given that we probably have a very wide
range of backgrounds I want to I want to
sort of level the playing field by
starting with something that everybody
understands these are the differential
equations of motion of a bicycle and the
point here is that you do not learn to
ride a bicycle through the city of your
intellect but through the seat of your
pants so my philosophy in teaching and
in this webinar is to connect the seat
of the intellect to the seat of the
pants and I call that limbic analytics
here's a sensitive rendition from my
book from the cartoonist Jeff danciger
of someone engaged in limbic analytics
now let's start where let's dive right
in to a project that has we're doing
project risk analysis here a project
that has uncertain durations so here I
have a project let's say we're building
out a website and we have 10 pages that
need to be completed page one could be
product one then we have product two
then we have the shopping cart page then
we have a legal page these ten these ten
pages are being created in parallel by
ten separate teams and it's the easiest
kind of project to imagine because
there's no you don't have to finish this
one before you do this one but there are
these ten teams and of course you're
uncertain how long it will take for each
team to finish but you can't go live
until all ten teams are done so
what typically happens now as the boss
walks in and says when do we go live and
you typically say I don't know boss
because I don't know how long team one
will take or team two or team three and
then the boss will say something like
give me a number and I don't know if any
of your organizations use that phrase
but give me a number is the fork in the
road to hell because once you've given a
specific number you really can't do any
reasonable analysis now let's just
remember what we have here each of these
times to completion is uncertain but
everybody agrees that on average each
one will take six weeks given that given
that what's the chance of finishing in
six weeks so a hundred percent fifty
percent
taking a while for this poll to fill in
okay we have a winner and so the winner
oh this is great and I hope we can save
these such as of the winner is 50% all
right well that's not right
by the way but it is the winner it had
almost double what the others did okay
so let's move on now and let me explain
that the actual answer is one in a
thousand and it's not just enough to
know that it's one in a thousand which
most of you didn't but you've got to be
able to explain it to a ten-year-old or
your boss so look at it this way the
only way in which this project finishes
in six weeks or less is if all ten of
these finished in six weeks or less and
if you imagine each one had a 50/50
chance of being greater or less than six
weeks then that's like flipping ten
heads in a row on a coin which is
actually 1,024 but hey I will live with
one in a thousand got that now actually
this is pretty serious stuff the bulk of
people in our little poll said oh yeah
50-50 chance we'll be done within six
weeks when there's a one in a thousand
chance of being done in six weeks so
that's actually not close enough even
for government work this is what I call
the flaw of averages here's another
cartoon from my book this is a
statistician drowning in a river that's
on average three feet deep the flow of
averages states that plans based on
average assumptions are wrong on average
and let me say this is based on a well
known mathematical principle called
Jensen's inequality but even most
mathematicians haven't heard of that so
it is a very important topic and it
requires some public relations
for people to understand it so let me
give you another more sobering example
consider a drunk wandering back and
forth on a busy highway
his average position is the center line
so the state of the drunken at his
average position is alive but on average
he's dead again not close enough even
for government work now because this is
really a public relations campaigning on
my part and that's really the nonprofit
has a lot to do with that as well I've
come up with an audio logo for the flaw
of averages so everyone know an audio
logo is this is the audio logo for Intel
I'm sure you all recognize that so
here's the audio logo for the flaw of
averages now let's go sort of discuss
how to how to attack this problem there
is a cure for the flaw of averages which
is really why that the nonprofit is
around and it involves two recent
breakthroughs these are things that most
people are not aware of the first
breakthrough is that native spreadsheets
are now powerful enough to do
interactive simulation a lot of our our
our audience here is familiar with Monte
Carlo simulation and I'll bet you're not
aware that native excel can do it
without any macros or add-ins and it can
do it incredibly fast you're gonna I'm
going to demonstrate that in just a
second the other breakthrough is that
there are new standards that communicate
uncertainties as auditable data and that
has led to the discipline of probability
management which I'll be describing a
little bit further it's a it's a simple
idea that is uncertainties are modeled
as any other kind of data
auditable data and i want to point out
here that this is really the most
important message of the webinar that
due to these two breakthroughs anyone
anywhere with Excel can be curing the
flaw of averages so let me demonstrate
this using dice because we all have a
pretty good understanding of how about
dice work the first comment is that
we're gonna represent the uncertainty of
these dice as a raise of die rolls so if
I look down here right my first roll is
a 4 or 6 and a 5 the second one is a 3 a
2 and a 6 and this goes down 10,000
times which is 10,000 dials I can look
at any roll oh by the way I remember the
roll nine thousand seven hundred sixty
five is three ones you wouldn't want to
bet against me because it's just
auditable data I haven't memorized all
10,000 of them but that was distinctive
so I remembered that but now is the
amazing thing in native Excel using
something called the data table data
what-if analysis data table and I'm sure
that at least two or three percent of
the audience is familiar with a data
table most people aren't but the data
table lets me roll these dice incredibly
fast so I'm going to say I'm gonna roll
the first die 10,000 times and we're
gonna see the percentages of ones twos
threes fours fives and sixes okay get
out your stopwatch on your mark get set
go
did you time that no of course not it
was instantaneous
instant stimulation in native Excel here
let's add the results of two types
together so when I do this I get the
numbers between 2 and 12 2 is the
smallest 12 is the biggest do I get all
the numbers in between with equal
probability if anyone thinks so I hope
brought their wallet yes there is no
it's not even anymore
there were many ways to get a 7 a 1 to 6
or 6 a 1 or 5 in a 2 or 3 all those
there's only one way to get a 2 to ones
or 12 2 sixes this was native excel
it's an xlsx file I could immediately
send this to a billion of my closest
friends and look I can undo it as well
ctrl Z minus 10000 ctrl Z another 10,000
control Y plus 10,000 so if you're in
the Monte Carlo simulation you should be
excited to learn that native excel can
do interactive Montecarlo interactive
bono con allah means that you can do
limbic analytics and ride this thing
like a bicycle so this is really a
miracle this is this has done for
simulation what ColdFusion would have
done for energy fit it actually worked
all right now let's go back to this
problem I'm going to show you how we
would use this in a practical setting
first thing to tell you is yes we have a
sip library now so in the age of big
data a lot of people have data on how
long it takes to do this task on that
task and so it's relatively easy to set
up a sip library like this so that means
that when I'm scrolling along here look
at this that could happen or that could
happen or that could happen I'm
scrolling through like a thousand
parallel universes and notice we're now
doing limbic analytics you could show
this to your boss right hey boss this
could happen if this kind of unnoticed
we don't go live until the last of these
are done and it's uncertain and holy
Toledo I don't see how Oh ever be done
in six weeks so I've done this all the
time with managers and this really
catches their attention
remember limbic analytics ties into the
reptilian brain you know
you see the movement and it's like that
scene out of Jurassic Park where the
guys waving the flashlight back and
forth
the Tyrannosaurus sees movement and so
does your manager all right but let's
make this let's thicken the plot a
little bit here suppose there were a
contract with performance penalties so
okay someone told them we've done in
seven weeks and you agreed to a late
penalty of a hundred thousand per week
or fraction thereof if you're late
oh how does that gonna look well if you
plug in all the average assumptions
you're done in six weeks with no penalty
great but I'm not as interested in that
as I am the following I want to know the
average of all thousand of these things
see scenario three scenario 4 we're
gonna do this a thousand times I want
the average of those numbers overall
thousand scenarios that's what the flaw
of averages about it says that the
numbers you get when you plug in the
average is not the same as the average
over all scenarios so remember plug in
the averages you're done in six weeks
with no penalty but on average you're
done in seven point eight weeks with
almost eighty seven thousand dollars in
penalty not close enough even for folk
music now let's see how we would manage
in a situation like this first of all
hopefully the this the contract has not
been signed yet so you go running back
and you go to the counterparty you say
oh please please please pretty please
would you give us a $50,000 penalty and
they say happy to do it as long as you
finish in six weeks oh no now we have a
ninety two thousand dollar penalty on
average cricket control-z a couple times
we don't want to do that well guys would
you let us finish in eight weeks and
they say sure but now we're jacking our
penalty up to
fifty-thousand hey we're taking that
deal look now are penalties down to
23,000 just in native Excel so I hope
you see that there's a there there we
could really be doing this stuff and we
can be doing it we could be doing it now
so there is a template in native Excel
that does a much bigger job of this in
fact if you go to in Excel 2016 their
templates for doing all sorts of special
things they have several of them that do
Gantt charts so this what you're looking
at here is is very much like the little
tiny example but in this one some tasks
have to precede other tasks and it's all
done deterministically just basically
these are the numbers and flow of
averages and all that I don't this into
a sit math model now we refer to the
data containing the uncertainties as a
set so the die rolls thought that those
10,000 trials for each die that was
called a sip why did I use it well your
ought you already have a little spot in
your mind for bit and byte so I knew I
needed sip and slurp so it would like
fit into the same little slot sip stands
for stochastic information packet and
and we will and refer to sip math as
running these sips to excel or any other
program as well if I click the sip math
button suddenly this is looking at a
thousand trials set math offset math on
in this model and now if I scroll
through the trials look out over here
you see that's where the project ends
way down there on the right and as I
scroll through that can happen or that
can happen or that can happen to that
and again this is just native Excel
another very common sort of risk in
projects is will the project pay for
itself will you make money and how big
an investment should you make because
you don't know what the market size is
right so demand is always uncertain when
you're doing a new a new product so
let's do another example very classic
one you know you could argue that these
models are just so small they're
unrealistic I say okay then I presume
you can small solve the small ones in
your head apparently not
most people thought that little project
was going to be done had a 50/50 chance
of being done in in six weeks and it's
only one in a thousand so here's another
one's little counterintuitive we've got
a new project product or service I guess
it's it's just a product and the actual
demand is uncertain but the average is a
hundred thousand so the capacity the
cost of capacity is thirty dollars a
unit and the selling price per unit is
forty dollars a unit now since the
average demand is a hundred thousand
we're gonna plan for capacity of 100,000
good now the boss walks in and says well
it's profit going to be and you say I
don't know boss because I don't know
what the man is gonna be and the boss
says give me a number cuz he's the boss
and you say would you settle for an
average profit well if that's all you
can give me so you say look we all agree
there's an average demand of a hundred
thousand yes the boss says we all agree
so we're gonna stock huh we're gonna
have a capacity of a hundred thousand
yeah that all makes sense
okay we'll expect sales of a hundred
thousand we're gonna make four million
from your 40 bucks apiece we're gonna
the cost
of good soul the fact that we had to
tool up and you know build these things
is 3 million and therefore the profit is
1 million okay well let's just address
this for a second
what if the demand was 80,000 remember
we're not certain about the demand and
the first thing I would do would be put
in a value a little below a little below
on a thousand little above a hundred
thousand just the first step let's just
do these experiments take it out to
80,000 and you didn't make your million
dollars did you only made two hundred
thousand sure but we know that a hundred
thousand was just the average so could
be greater it could be it could be like
120,000 yeah see well wait a minute
you're hosed you you've got a demand of
a hundred twenty thousand you only have
a capacity of a hundred thousand there's
this nasty little if statement in here
that says that if the actual demand is
greater than the capacity you are stuck
with a capacity otherwise you feel the
actual demand so if we look down at the
bottom the bottom line is the profit is
still a million a million isn't your
average profit a million is the best
best possible case alright so what do we
do about this
well I'd like to run a simulation here
is a problem with simulations I love
them I love them to death but the
general public can't use simulation
generally because they don't know how to
generate the required distributions of
random numbers this takes a statistician
or something this is a serious serious
block for using simulation but you know
one day I realized we all use with light
bulbs and yet we don't know how to
generate the electricity for our light
bulbs how do we do that well I figured
it out we have something called the
power grid and we run electricity
through the power grid it's generated by
experts and the rest of us use it but
what it required was a standard we call
it the 60 cycle AC voltage standard and
the new data standards that I've
mentioned that that are maintained by
probability managers org are the
equivalent of this sixty cycle on a 20
volt AC current standard so now let's
talk about forecasting
because forecasting is actually where we
get the distribution of uncertainties
and it generally works like this by the
way you can get distributions of
uncertainties to feed your simulation
you can get that from almost any
simulation or excuse me from any
forecast you can get the distribution
from almost any forecast this one has a
95% upper lower confidence interval that
leads to a bell-shaped distribution and
typically so people will do this
analysis and they'll create the
distribution
and that's right folks they flush it
down the toilet
that's what they do with it they end up
with a single number and of course you
know what happens next so let me show
you how we deal with this in probability
management you're looking at a sip
library it was created using a forecast
I'm not even to go into the details of
it do you want to hear how the
electricity was generated that's
lighting the lightbulbs you're often
know you don't care you just want to use
the light bulb so think of this is the
electricity it's going to contain a
thousand possible demands for this new
product it has metadata so for example
the metadata tells oh yeah the average
demand is hundred thousand and it tells
us where the metadata is stored oh look
at those those are my initials
there's provenance in other it this is
not just a distribution that the cat
dragged in and if I click the plus sign
boom there are all thousand trials all
right so it's just a library now I'm
going to go back to this model and I'm
going to open the set math tools now
these are there's a free version of
these out on the website and everything
I'm doing here I could do by hand in
Excel but the tools make it a lot easier
and they're free so first thing I'm
going to do is initialize my model and
I'm gonna say select a library to plug
into I'm going to go to an external
workbook and webinar and oh there it is
demand so here's the library for demand
for my product now I put the cursor in
this cell
the library input ask for demand Oh a
there's a little distribution there look
at that is that cute
that's called a sparkline graph in excel
and we're now dialed in to all those
thousand possible demands so I can go to
demand - there's only 75 thousand by the
way look at that I only made $23,000
that time demand 3 I made my million
it's audible I remember number 9 isn't
very nice 9 okay why isn't it let me
type typing not let's get down let's get
up to 9 here 9 is worth looking at
because on trial 9 we only had 66,000
demand and we lost 325 million dollars
so remember you told the boss this is
basically hey expect a million bucks and
the boss would say we didn't tell me
about the chance of losing 325 million
let's go back and look at the average
here there's our average and what we see
is that we make a million bucks right
now what's happened here is that when I
initialize the model it created another
sheet in back where the data table is
going to put the simulation and what I'm
going to do now is put my cursor in the
profit cell define that as an output
click over here and a thousand trials
later
whew there's another nice little graph
there and what this is showing me is
that profit isn't bell-shaped at all
profit is limited on the upside by a
million dollars now here's the cool part
there is now a range on this sheet
named prophet that's a column of a
thousand parallel universes of prophet
and that means I can go up here and I
can type equals average of prophet so
the profit of the average is a million
the average prophet has got to be less
right because it can either go down from
a million or be it a million but the
average is something less than a million
and a million can be less but how much
less oh my dad six hundred thousand so
the the profit of the average is a
million the average profit is six
hundred thousand how do you run a
business this way now at this point I'm
gonna discuss what I call the levels of
stochastic enlightenment so let me be
clear here
part of limbic analytics is to explain
everything to like to a ten-year-old so
in the flaw of averages book I've got
this concept of red words and green
words a red word is some technical thing
you heard in a statistics course and it
would just give you PTSD to hear it
again and in the back there's a back of
the book there's a red word green word
glossary and maybe consumed in on that
ooh and if we can see that or not red
word but the important thing notices the
red words are written in dracula font
that was that was the publishers idea i
love it so the the the best way to
define a red word is something that
could not be uttered in a singles bar
now here i have a red word stochastic
and i'm using it to pay poke fun at it
but I'm talking about the levels of
stochastic enlightenment which means how
do you deal with uncertainty so let's
start with level
zero dumb the boss comes in and says
what's profit going to be and you say I
don't know boss cuz I don't know what
profits gonna be a good step below dumb
level minus one dumber
use the average demand and say oh bus
we're gonna make a million bucks let me
point out that this is also accepted
press practice worse than that it's
actually GAAP generally accepted
accounting principles that's horrible
step one smart level one smart simulate
right simulating you know how many
people have heard about garbage in
garbage out oh yeah it's garbage in
garbage out you put in a bad
distribution you got a bad simulation
wrong when you shake a ladder before you
climb on it to paint the side of your
house you are performing a Monte Carlo
simulation on the ladder bombarded it
with random forces and monitoring the
response of the ladder I got bad news
for you
the distribution of forces when you
shake a ladder is very different than
when you climb on it so I want to know
out of all our attendees we should have
a survey for this but we don't how many
of you are gonna stop shaking ladders
now that I've told you you've been using
the wrong distribution for your whole
life
no simulate it's smart garbage in
insight out but let's go to the next
step
smarter optimize let's go back to our
problem over here so if you've done the
right analysis you would know now that
this million dollar project is worth
$600,000 average ain't great can you do
something to make the situation better
so let me remind you that any demand
over a hundred percent over on 2000
excuse me which is the average like
anything
and over a hundred thousand is not going
to be met because you only stock the
average down here so seems to me we
should we should increase capacity to
above 100,000 well that might be risky
because you have to spend more money to
do that right yeah it's 30 30 bucks a
pop for that additional fee maybe we
should make a capacity smaller maybe we
should leave it as it is oh my gosh I
don't know what to do what do you think
we should do let's take a poll so our
average profit is now six hundred
thousand to increase that average profit
should we increase our capacity and
spend more money to make a bigger
capacity should we decrease our capacity
will won't spend as much money or should
we maintain current capacity what do
people think about this looks like a lot
of head-scratching going on out there
okay the increased capacity winds got
47% decreased capacity is about 30% and
stay the same as 23% okay very good so
let's go back up the the winners wanted
to increase capacity so let's do that
let's just Jack this up to say 120,000
remember what we're trying to beat down
here is 600,000 here goes hundred twenty
thousand and our profit dropped our
average profit dropped by more than half
down to 279 now that's reduced capacity
to 80,000 and it goes up from 600
thousand six hundred almost 80,000
fantastic now let me make a confession
this is a problem out of one of my
textbooks and I designed this problem so
that we more profitable to increase
capacity so I designed the problem and
then I simulated it and it said no it's
less profitable increased capacity and
then I say oh I must be wrong
no I said oh I must have built my model
wrong and I went through that phase of
denial for you know 10 or 15 minutes
till I thought it no I was wrong the
answer this question is and the next
time you see a question like this
should we make more should we make less
should be the answer is you can't do
this in your head so don't try alright
oh now let's go to the next phase with
this thing and do a bunch a bunch of
simulations for different capacities so
what we've done in this case is we've
run seven simulations
where we have a fifty thousand sixty
thousand seventy eighty ninety one
hundred hundred ten thousand capacity
and it's important to understand what
we're graphing the blue line is the
average profit for those different
levels of capacity the red line is the
10% the tenth percentile which means
there's a 10% risk that we will fall
below that line right so just for
example I like to think of this line is
risk so okay
80 is the best you can see at the graph
you make six hundred seventy nine
thousand on average yeah but there's a
ten percent chance of making twenty
thousand dollars or less now one of
things I have to say here about risk I
don't like to use the word at risk it
takes a lot of caveats before you use
that that word you got to really know
what you're talking about
here's a question for you is there a
risk that IBM stock will go down next
week
heck no I've shorted the stuff the risk
for me is that it goes up risk is in the
eye of the beholder you must always
remember uncertainty
well uncertainty is just like you know
stuff happens right so is IBM stock
price uncertain yes
is there a risk that it goes up for me
yes is a risk it goes down for you on
IBM stock yes
so let's I'm a little hesitant to really
nail down the word risk but let's look
at this we started here at 100,000 we
were stock we were we had a capacity of
on 2000 well that only gave us sixty six
hundred thousand average profit oh yeah
and a 10% chance of losing almost six
hundred thousand so stocking a hundred
thousand or having the capacity of on
two thousand is nuts
in fact
why would anyone do anything greater
than 8080 maximize your profit and gives
you less risk than these other ones so I
got to draw a straight line here any
strategy to the right of that line is
nuts now let's back up what if I back
down to 70,000 well I lose a little
average profit don't I came down a
little bit
a little over 600,000 what about Mike
what about the risk of bad outcomes
well now look my worst popular 10th
percentile outcome and my average are
closed up on each other there's almost
no uncertainty there so there's way less
risk so if we have a capacity of 70,000
we have minimum risk so is 70 is 70,000
nuts know this depends on your risk
attitude if you want to go for broke and
have the highest average profit you go
to 80 if you want to cover your butt and
minimize the chance for downside you go
to 70 but how about less than 70 it's
nuts because the redline is coming back
down and the blue line is coming back
down so when you're doing simulation
analysis there may not be one right
answer it's going to depend on your risk
attitude there's a range of answers that
are not nuts everything else is just
crazy here though all right now let's
move on to operational risk and we've
been doing some exciting work with PG&E
here in Northern California there's an
article in the December 2016 o RMS today
and I believe there there's links to
this at our at the probability
management website I think we have links
other places around will get you those
links it really it gives you a nice
flavor for how probability management
works and I want to give you an example
now when we say rolling up risk
one of the great great benefits of using
sips is that we can roll up the results
of independent simulations just think of
the two sips of the dice right I could
add the first two elements together in
the second two and the third down to the
$10,000
of the sum of the dice and adding up
uncertainties is just not that easy to
do so here's an example now this is not
a real live model I mean it's real and
lie but it is of not of a real situation
it's sort of like a balsa airplane of a
model we've got 10,000 trials here we
have a bunch of gas pipeline assets
pipes valves fittings for each asset I
have three sips representing financial
risk safety risk reliability risk
they're stored in a sip library you saw
what that looks like now in Excel is
just pure Excel I've got a bunch of you
have seen these little filter things
right where you can actually say oh just
show me some of the some of the rows by
the way we've rolled up the total
financial risk up here
the total safety risk the total
reliability risk let me go to the asset
tab and let me say hey let's just look
at the pipes click and that was 10,000
trials now of the conditional risk given
that we're just looking at the pipes now
how do you know if you have a risk model
you should be able to tell me the chance
of something bad happening so for
example for example what's the chance
that the financial risk is over 40
million it's 100 percent apparently okay
what if I change that to see
million oh there's only a 30% chance
that the risk is greater than that that
the financial loss will be greater than
60 million
what about 55 million 78 percent so if
you can't do that you don't have a risk
model you gotta be able to tell me the
chances of something happening now
another thing discussed in that article
and what I'm showing you now I don't
think anyone in the world has fully
implemented yet I call it a consolidated
risk statement because we're still in
pretty early innings with probability
management were making a lot of a lot of
strides and and the technology is
changing fast but here's the idea behind
a consolidated risk statement that I've
got three kinds of risks financial
safety reliability oh but I've got I'm
gonna roll it off across a couple
divisions this really has not been
possible in the past to easily add up
the results of different simulations
running on different platforms Excel
MATLAB are you can do sit math with
10,000 people with abacuses the first
person would do the first number the
second person I mean it's just a very
general open concept
oh these divisions yeah well the
divisions have business units right and
then what goes into these risks here
well of course probability distributions
go in and so there's the financial risk
the safety risk through liability risk
and let's drill down a little further
so in risk management there's an
important concept known as the risk
exceedance curve and it's really just
the flip side of a of a probability
cumulative curve so let me zoom in on
this here we have financial risk I'm
looking at the blue curve and let me run
out here to the blue curve and it tells
me that there is a 30% chance of losing
a thirty six point four million dollars
or more right and that's right here it's
a thirty percent level now there's a red
curve on here as well
remember we said risk is in the eye of
the beholder there's a red curve on here
that represents your risk tolerance and
this means if we go down to this end of
the curve that you can tolerate more
risk than you actually have that's good
but when I get down here and your risk
tolerance is below the blue curve then
that's it says you can't live with that
right let's see what this red curve says
right here click on that it says there's
a 10% chance of we can tolerate a 10%
chance of losing thirty-eight point
three million dollars yep if I go up
here we see that there's actually like a
20% chance of that
all right no now here we have some
limbic analytics going on I am going to
invoke insurance now against that
financial risk and watch the curves
change oh the insurance brought the blue
curve down below my red curve so I'm
feeling comfortable all right now let's
just do a quick time check I have one
more example I can do or we can stop for
questions here do one more example
okay so this next one is an example
involving the risk of a project R&D
portfolio and so this is it's based on a
real-world example that all the numbers
have been changed and anonymized and we
don't talk about the actual company but
I was approached by folks at one point
who said the way we model and take a
look think of a big R&D pharmaceutical
was about a hundred pharmaceutical
products 100 drugs in the pipeline very
very risky and first of all they had
trouble mom they could model the
finances of any individual drug what
they couldn't do was roll them up into a
portfolio to understand the portfolio
risk and furthermore there were a lot of
portfolio effects this is the kind of
thing that sips can do very well you can
use sips to roll up risk well one of the
issues was this that if you look at the
return lifetime revenue of a drug that
it's very uncertain the bulk of them
make almost nothing and there are a few
whoppers out here viagra and lipitor
just made tons and tons of money
the average drug makes about a billion
and so they were saying is we've been
using this 1 billion to represent the
revenue of a drug but gee maybe we
should be simulating that because there
really is a distribution and I thought
yeah maybe you should so let's take a
look at what happened
they were simulating a whole bunch of
different pharmaceuticals at different
drugs and they were doing them under a
bunch of different conditions that
affected all the drugs at once like the
what's the discount rate
what's the probability of success of
different classes of drugs and so in
particular one of the things we were
able to look at is well what would
happen if you use the 1 billion average
versus you use the full distribution
okay let's see if the difference is big
enough to view in the naked eye by the
way imagine now this is all make-believe
numbers but suppose our NPV target net
present value target is 5 a billion well
right now it's showing we have a 97
percent chance of achieving that target
but but that's because we're using a
single average over here okay now I'm
going to use the full distribution and
by the way this is going to be 5,000
trials when I click this over a hundred
drugs many many experiments it's like
300 million numbers running through this
model ok I'm going to click the full
distribution and see if you can tell the
difference okay full distribution of
drug prices 1 billion average instead of
the full distribution so the average
folk okay can you tell the difference
okay now shut your eye your left eye
okay is that better or is that better oh
and by the way check over here the
chance of achieving your 5 billion
target went from 97 percent to 44
percent ok 97 percent to 44 percent
those aren't close enough even for folk
music alright so with that I think I'd
like to hear from the audience see what
questions you have
thank you very much Sam for this
informative presentation and hope all of
us can walk away feeling more
knowledgeable about your work in this
field and now we will move on to
answering your questions so the first
question is your presentation was
incredibly engaging can you talk about
what the course will be like how will it
be structured and what kinds of assign
assignments will there be so none of my
successes have been planned and none of
my plans have been successful that's why
I do stochastic modeling my life is
uncertain the class will depend on on
the students who
take it but it would project-based so
one of the first things we're going to
learn is what I call the arithmetic of
uncertainty and it will all be done in
Excel and virtually every week you'll
have new Excel projects to do but what I
really want to do is have students go
out and search for real-world projects I
am in negotiations now with some with
some companies that have project data
and I'd like to have the students try to
create SIF libraries so that for example
suppose I'm pouring concrete somewhere
and you know I know that the temperature
is going to be between 60 and 80 degrees
and I have to pour 150 yards of concrete
I'd like to be able to have a
distribution of how long that concrete
will take to set up and I'd like to find
build libraries like this and then be
able to assemble them into bigger
projects Oh a little bit like that Gantt
chart you saw that's in in Excel be fun
to populate that with real distributions
okay and the second question is your
presentation did an excellent job
clearly communicating statistics how
would the clear communication of
statistical ideas be incorporated into
the class well as I mentioned I like to
have explanations that a ten-year-old
will understand my motto is this stuff
is easy to explain the hard part is
getting anyone to understand it and at
the end of the class they're going to be
class presentation so we're not going to
have a final we're gonna have a class
project right and the the class project
requires you to get up there and not
explain it you don't get any points for
explaining it you get points for getting
people to understand what you're doing
and so I will encourage class
participation and learning how to how to
explain things clearly
ends up being probably way more
important than even getting the analysis
right or you can't get I don't even
think you can get the analysis right if
you can't explain it clearly they're
just too intimately tied up and and
people don't spend nearly as much time
on the communication aspect so for me
you know I think of myself as basically
a public relations guy this Jensen's
inequality has been around for over a
hundred years and no one knows about it
so Jensen's inequality is my anchor
tenant and of course the flaw of
averages is the word I gave it to try to
get people to understand it and we only
have time for one more question this
kind of analysis depends on the data you
use for a simulation in your course will
you be covering best practices for
collecting data I will certainly cover
approaches for gathering data there
there are a number of them the first
thing is that people get too hung up on
that so remember is shaking the ladder
close counts with horseshoes hand
grenades and simulation and by the way
there are some recent advances that
really that helped us turn data into
SIPP libraries it's very exciting I'm
working with some colleagues on that now
and we'll certainly spend plenty of time
on that but we also have to get you
basically over the hump of doing it with
very little data don't get blocked by
that oh I'll just say one last thing
about this some people say oh no no I
couldn't I couldn't simulate anything
cuz I don't have enough data right if
you don't have enough data that means
you are very very uncertain about what's
going on
so saying I couldn't do analysis because
I don't have enough data is like saying
I couldn't learn how to use a parachute
because the wing of the airplane is on
fire
thank you very much Sam for answering
these questions we're at the top the
hours unfortunately we will not have
time for additional questions if you'd
like to learn more about the course
please don't hesitate to reach out to us
directly our contact information is
available on our website SCPD
da stanford.edu also make sure to check
your inbox for the webinar recording
within the next two weeks thank you
again for joining us today and we wish
you all the best as you pursue your
education goals thanks for attending
you